hey everybody it's great to be back in
the studio we had the 4th of July
holiday over the weekend and it's not
it's not really feeling like a great
time to be proud about being an American
or living in the United States and it's
only getting worse as restrictions on
where Americans are allowed to go around
the world continue to grow we talked I
mean listen I said months ago that it's
likely that as other countries get
coronavirus under control and we don't
because of our failed incompetent
leadership we will not be allowed to
participate in the travel that is now
becoming commonplace in other parts of
the world and case in point the United
States is included in a list of
countries from which people cannot
travel to Europe despite Europe being
widely reopened spoke to friends in
France and Belgium over the weekend and
you know they're taking precautions
masks on public transit but restaurants
are open things are happening people are
traveling between European countries
Americans not allowed to go there it's
getting even worse now the Mexican state
of Sonora has closed the border to the
United States specifically their border
is with the state of Arizona ahead of
the July 4th weekend the governor of
Sonora
saying that American travelers are not
going to be allowed to come in there's
too much of a risk with coronavirus
being rampant in Arizona and in the
United States they don't want Americans
on Sonoran beaches July 4th is a peak
tourism time for Americans going over
there now before we go even further is
anybody else a little bit confused about
going to another country to celebrate
our Independence Day I mean I guess
conceptually if you just think about it
as time off then you go wherever there's
no rule that says you have to stay in
the United States but it is interesting
that in a state like Arizona which is
not a particularly progressive state
there would be so much desire on our
Independence Day to leave the country
and to go to Mexico I guess if you're
under 21 it makes more sense because you
can drink in Mexico and not in the
United States legally anyway but there's
something about that that's maybe a
little bit counterintuitive but in any
case in any case Americans not allowed
to cross the border from Arizona into
Sonora a reopening date has
not yet been announced and it's just too
dangerous Americans are a danger to
Mexico Mexico having its own fair share
of troubles controlling coronavirus but
Arizona one of the global hotspots at
this point never mind
one of the American hot spots the growth
rate of cases in Arizona one at one of
the largest in the world and it does
seem I mean listen I understand why
they're doing it I don't like that we
can't travel to Europe I had a trip to
Europe planned in June obviously it was
canceled I was hoping that I could
reschedule it to August I haven't and it
doesn't look like that's going to be
even remotely safe so I'm not going to
do it so from a personal perspective I
don't like it but you have to imagine
that a lot of the people going from
Arizona to Mexico for the 4th of July
during a pandemic are not going to be
what we would call our best to borrow a
term from Donald Trump it's probably the
anti maskers maybe anti-vaxxers as well
conspiracy theorists the so-called
Liberty people maybe birthers truthers
of different persuasions trumpets and
gun people queuing ins and of course
because of the virus probably some kovat
people as well because who else would
really be doing for unnecessary foreign
travel right now is dr. Anthony foul she
recently said he would only get onto an
airplane in an emergency right now so
the numbers in Arizona are horrifying
ninety-eight thousand total cases
probably by the end of today Arizona
will be at a hundred thousand total
cases approaching two thousand deaths
very fast growth rate peak death number
so far in Arizona was just a few days
ago July 1st is the day on which Arizona
has had the most single day deaths and
looking at case numbers it would not be
shocking that they best that in the next
few days Sonora in Mexico the state of
Sonora their hospitals are filling up
their testing capacity is limited they
can't afford a spike
so they're saying sorry Americans you
can't come here so parts of Mexico are
now closed to Americans the Canadian
border is closed except for essential
travel with mandatory quarantine can't
fly to Europe they wanted nationalism
were sort of weirdly getting this
isolationist nationalism not exact
actually by our choice but happening as
a result of other countries instituting
limitations on Americans the optimistic
hopeful scenario right now I don't want
to blow smoke anywhere you know up down
wherever it is you don't want a smoke
blown I don't want to blow it
but the optimistic scenario right now is
Biden defeats Trump when he takes over
in January we likely still have a huge
mess hopefully by then there's an early
vaccine there's initial vaccine access
by January I think optimistic would be
health care workers and some of the most
vulnerable and it will still probably be
six months beyond that of Biden focusing
heavily on coronavirus to really get
things under control economically and
medically we're going to talk about the
economic component in a little bit and
of course a lot of this will depend on
Republican obstruction which is why
taking control of the Senate in November
in addition to removing Donald Trump is
so clearly important and because we're
here for the full week this week no days
off this week later this week I'm going
to revisit the topic of the Senate which
i think is a really important one are
you a sick of winning as I am at this
point okay now let's talk about
coronavirus more broadly and what's
going on so we will do I'm not doing
these daily anymore but I'm sort of
doing these weekly or as the data
requires the big picture on coronavirus
is it's really really bad here in the
United States a lot of the world has
already figured out January 20th we got
our first case South Korea got their
first case they still have under 300
total deaths at the last I checked we
are obviously doing much much worse than
that around 125,000 deaths in total
right now in terms of cases we are
setting new records in terms of new
cases in the United States we had almost
60,000 new cases in a single day on July
2nd about 55,000 cases on July 3rd some
lower numbers over the weekend typically
over weekends and holiday weekends the
numbers decrease so we could have today
and tomorrow some huge numbers as a
result of catching up on underreporting
over the weekend now a good thing is
that death numbers are
down there's this growing idea on the
right that the evil left the Marxist
socialist left doesn't want to admit
that deaths are down despite cases being
up
oh I'm readily admitting it and there's
about five or six different
possibilities about why it's going on I
don't want a single person to die I
don't want a single person to get
coronavirus and I hope that that
continues and we'll talk about why that
may be going on in a little bit in terms
of cases the hot spots are Florida Texas
California remains a hot spot Georgia
Arizona the Carolinas Tennessee it's
mostly red states plus California
Florida set a major record with the most
new cases in a single week of any state
since the start of the pandemic they had
over 59 thousand cases in a seven day
period last week the Phoenix Arizona
mayor has admitted they opened up too
early this is not the Republican
governor of Arizona this is merely
merely an important person but what I
mean is they are speaking only from
their democratic perspective as mayor of
Phoenix take a look at this we opened
way too early in Arizona we were one of
the last States to go to stay at home
and one of the first to reimagine we
reached at zero to 60 we had crowded
nightclubs handing out free champagne no
masks our twenty to forty four year olds
which is my own demographic really led
the explosion and we've seen such growth
in that area we're seeing a lot of
people go to large family gatherings and
infect their family members we are in a
crisis related to testing was visiting a
testing facility this weekend people
waiting still eight hours good for her
for admitting it friends of mine in
Arizona say it's an insane situation
hospital capacity is rapidly filling up
in Texas University of Texas Austin
researchers expect hospitals in Texas
will are in Austin rather will be over
capacity potentially by the end of the
month the mayor of Austin says they're
in trouble and a reality we're learning
is so we learned early that governors
have to deal with the reality on the
ground where as Trump doesn't Trump can
just say we're putting out the embers
and everything's going great governor's
have to deal with the real situation
some of the governor's choose to ignore
the reality like for example we saw this
in Texas we're seeing it in Florida
Arizona mayors ee have to deal with the
realities that sometimes governor's
don't have to deal with how many of our
hospitals are full right now do we have
to start telling people in Phoenix that
they've got to maybe go to Tucson if
they want to if they need an ICU bed for
example so mayor's are increasingly
sounding the alarm now let's get back to
this question why are deaths so low
compared to these new case numbers
because when you look at the case
numbers we're having now bigger than
we've ever had before the death numbers
are only a fraction of what we were
having in April and early May that's a
good thing we don't want people tonight
to die but we want to know why this is
going on deaths continue to trend down
so there's a few possibilities we've
discussed all of which are still on the
table one is that there's just a lag
between cases and deaths as the
hospitals get better at treating people
earlier in the disease it may take even
longer to be very sort of dark for
people to die and so the deaths haven't
yet happened from a lot of these early
cases the ideas you need about 19 to 21
days for a case to become a death if
it's going to we're on day 17 right now
so if the explanation is that we just
haven't seen the deaths yet from these
new cases we would expect the deaths to
spike sometime in the middle or the end
of this week we're gonna watch that
another hypothesis is there's now a less
deadly strain which may be more
contagious in other words it spreads
more easily but it is less severe so it
will cause fewer deaths per case that's
an assertion we've not seen actual
evidence of that yet we want to be
careful number three some states could
just be lying I mean that that's the the
the you know it's it's a very simplistic
explanation but from what we've seen in
Florida and some other states it's
possible states are seeing more deaths
but they're simply lying about it again
we need evidence to really believe that
the fourth possibility is that
increasingly it's younger people now
testing positive so even though the
total case numbers are going up
the number of people in the high-risk
age groups are less likely to be getting
it now
because they're staying home and so a
lot of these young cases are not
ultimately going to lead to deaths
number five is increased testing means
that in general you have less sick
people getting tests at an earlier point
tests were so difficult to come by that
you they were really restricted to
people who were much more ill now in
those case numbers you have people but
you're capturing more of the cases and a
lot of those cases are less severe
that's a possibility and then number six
is some combination of these factors and
or something that we don't yet know so
we're going to keep watching it I have
no desire to see deaths go up for
political reasons as I've already told
you the case for removing Donald Trump
is crystal clear without a single
additional death and we will have
certainly in the next 72 hours a lot
more information about whether we can
cross some of these possibilities off
the list or whether they are likely or
realistic hypotheses big announcement
today next Tuesday
okay Tuesday July 14th we have two
things going on the third David Pakman
show chess tournament okay
Tuesday night 8:00 p.m. Eastern third
David Pakman show chess tournament we're
doing one a month that will be the July
tournament and and and and very exciting
we will have a huge one-day membership
special you don't have to play the chess
tournament to get the membership special
we took unfortunately at the end of June
last year we had a ton of members sign
up because of a promo we ran a lot of
those yearly memberships came up for
renewal in the last week and because of
the virus a lot of people were unable to
renew so we unfortunately had like our
biggest three-day loss of memberships
that we've ever had so next Tuesday
we're gonna try to get some of these
folks back and bring in new people so we
will have a single day membership
special on Tuesday we will also have the
chess tournament that day a make sure to
be notified about both just get on my
mailing list go to david pakman.com top
right of the website you can subscribe
to the mailing list very very excited
let me know what's going on in your
state in terms of the virus I'm on
Twitter at AIPAC the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
new members of the day are Ashley D
Ralph and Deborah Jackman Ashley and
Deborah thank you so much for your
support and I also want to thank today's
longtime sustaining member of the day
Lance
riddle who's been a member for almost 5
years thanks to all of you grab a
membership at join pakman.com cheap
quick easy feels good you get the daily
bonus show for members only and you're
supporting alternatives to homogenous
tired repetitive corporate media join
pakman.com is the place okay I am going
to give you video now of to absolutely
bonkers a speeches I guess I'm
hesitating to even call them speeches
public events at which Trump said things
over the fourth of July weekend now from
the from the perspective of rallies
Donald Trump has decided he's doing
rallies he did the rally in Tulsa
Oklahoma we've already started to see
cases rise and rise and rise in the
surrounding areas the rally itself was
just an absolute absolutely disgusting
combination of red meat and dog whistles
and fear-mongering combined with lies
and a donald trump was determined to
keep it going so on July 3rd Donald
Trump did an event at Mount Rushmore and
this was one where social distancing
would not be allowed they actually zip
tied the chairs together so people were
not able to spread the chairs apart
there was barely a mask in sight and
unfortunately after all of this build up
this was one of Donald Trump's were
speeches and again I sort of grimace at
even calling it that
incredibly low energy this was what
we're calling remember upper and downer
Trump I'm now calling it adderall Trump
and benzodiazepine Trump
this was benzodiazepine Trump a very
very low-energy Trump a glitching
noticeably multiple times on certain
words which I will play for you kind of
doing stream of consciousness type stuff
it was the verbal equivalent of an ink
blot or Rorschach test maybe the best
way to describe it extremely sweaty
gripping his lectern a white-knuckle in
it the audience was relatively low
energy so let's go through some of this
stuff we're gonna start with the
glitches and Donald Trump's trouble
speaking there was a lot of it he had a
major glitch on Jefferson if you're
watching this you'll see him verbally
catch on the word Jefferson and his
right shoulder twitches again and he
seems to do something very very odd
let's take a look at it a couple of
times
Thomas Jefferson the great Thomas
Jefferson Thomas Jefferson a great
Thomas Jefferson so let's pick it up
right after that Trump was mentioning
Thomas Jefferson essentially to start
reading Thomas Jefferson's biography in
total monotone very very weird part of
the speech
take a look Thomas Jefferson the great
Thomas Jefferson was 33 years old
when he traveled north to Pennsylvania
and brilliantly authored one of the
greatest treasures of human history the
Declaration of Independence he also
drafted Virginia's constitution and
conceived and wrote the Virginia statute
for religious freedom just bizarre right
I mean it sounds like Trump is reading
Jefferson's wiki bio off of off of a
prompter the crowd doesn't care more
importantly reading Tamil Thomas
Jefferson's biography has nothing to do
with Trump's failed governance or policy
or anything like it
Trump later mangling the word
totalitarianism calling it
totalitarianism take a look at that this
is the very definition of
totalitarianism and it is come
pletely alien to our culture and to our
values and it has absolutely no place in
the United States of America Trump again
going with you Lysias s grant of course
still can't say that one take a listen
Alyssia says grant abolitionists and
many others and this was actually part
of Trump just naming people this was
remember during 2015 and 2016 at his
rallies Trump would just read polls now
Trump just naming people during his
events we are the country of andrew
jackson ulysses s grant and frederick
douglass we are the land of Wild Bill
Hickok and Buffalo Bill Cody we are the
nation that gave rise to the Wright
brothers the Tuskegee Airmen Harriet
Tubman that went on for awhile I'm not
going to play all of it more struggles
talking continued struggling with
magnificent struggling with mountain
take a look at this be no better place
to celebrate America's independence than
beneath this magnificent incredible
majestic mountain and monument to the
greatest Americans who have ever lived
okay so a lot of difficulty speaking is
the point let's now get into the meat
and the content of this there's this new
strategy that Donald Trump is employing
during his public events pretend that
the left is some kind of Marxist fascist
nightmare take a look at this and again
very low-energy what he's saying is
crazy but he's delivering it in this
benzodiazepine sort of mode schools are
newsrooms even our corporate boardrooms
there is a new far-left fascism that
demands absolute allegiance if you do
not speak its language performance
rituals recite its mantras and follow
its commandments then you will be sent
banished blacklisted persecuted and
punished it's not going to happen to us
make no mistake this left-wing cultural
revolution is designed to overthrow the
American Revolution in so doing they
would destroy the very civilization that
rescued billions from poverty disease
violence and hunger and that lifted
humanity to new heights of achievement
discovery and progress to make this
possible they are determined to tear
down every statue symbol and memory of
our national heritage so Low Energy
seems to be on Downer's and the content
Cultural Revolution talking about the
left wants to overthrow the American
Revolution you you want to make the
United States just an offshoot and
belong to the United Kingdom I don't see
any leftists who want to do that and
just imagine for a second if a President
Barack Obama or another Democratic
president gave a speech about fighting
the extreme right wing and referenced
defeating Nazis in World War two and
fighting the Cold War or whatever as if
that's what's going on today if a
Democratic president did the equivalent
of what Donald Trump is doing here about
Marxism and people who want to undo the
American Revolution Fox News and Rush
Limbaugh and Hannity and Tucker and all
of them they would be going insane for a
week that's essentially what Trump is
doing and you have right-wing
pseudo-intellectuals like rich Lowry
saying this was a great speech if you
can believe that
monuments okay we've learned that Donald
Trump's staff want him to talk less
about monuments because they see it as
kind of a losing approach and again
Trump going on and on here about
monuments he also sounds like he's sleep
talking now it's more like ambien like
it's weird
gives an applause line the audience is
almost silence or trumped us waits and
finally gets some some reaction from the
crowd it's all very weird our nation is
witnessing a merciless campaign to wipe
out our history to fame our heroes erase
our values and indoctrinate our children
[Music]
angry mobs are trying to tear down
statues of our founders to face our most
sacred memorials and unleash a wave of
violent crime in our cities many of
these people have no idea why they're
doing this but some know exactly what
they are doing they think the American
people are weak and soft and submissive
wipeouts history and erase our values
how would taking down Confederate
statues erase our values I didn't think
our values were the values of the
Confederacy but maybe among Donald Trump
supporters those values are more common
than than maybe I believe living in
Massachusetts Trump then still seems not
to understand the basics of how a virus
works he talks about killing the virus
of course viruses are not actually alive
let us also send our deepest thanks to
our wonderful veterans law enforcement
first responders and the doctors nurses
and scientists working tirelessly to
kill the virus yeah so on their own
viruses can do nothing until they enter
a living cell like without cells viruses
would not be able to multiply so viruses
are not considered living things Trump
talks about killing the virus who cares
right it's the least of our concerns if
Trump took coronavirus seriously I
wouldn't care if he thought the virus
was a hybrid of a giraffe and a shark
I really wouldn't like if he was
actually dealing with it properly and
taking it seriously
he happens not to be and then lastly
here's another just super low-energy
part where I guess Trump is criticizing
Democrats it's not even clear what the
critique is I guess they're not for long
order or something and he says kids are
taught to hate their country cities that
are run by Liberal Democrats in every
case is the predictable result of years
of extreme indoctrination and bias and
education journalism and other cultural
institutions against every law of
society in nature our children are
taught in school to hate their own
country and to believe that the men and
women who built it were not heroes but
that were villains so the audience just
barely engaging with what Donald Trump
is saying and this was not the only
horrifying gongshow speech that Donald
Trump gave over the weekend this was
July 3rd in Mount Rushmore on July 4th
Donald Trump gave I guess what we're
calling his big 4th of July's speech and
that's what I want to talk about next
so as bad as the July 3rd speech at
Mount Rushmore was for Donald Trump and
certainly the July 3rd speech contained
way more verbal glitches it was what
we're calling benzodiazepine Trump I
previously referred to it as downer
Trump sometimes we say ambien Trump the
July 4th speech on the lawn of the White
House was absolutely terrifying and
Donald Trump actually taking some of the
same ideas from July 3rd about we're
fighting Marxists here in the United
States and actually building on them in
an even more cartoonish and dystopian
way Trump's big messages recycled things
from the previous night were essentially
we have agitators and looters and
anarchists and Marxists that we are
fighting against we are now in the
process of defeating the radical left
the Marxists the anarchists the
agitators the looters and people who in
many instances have absolutely no clue
what they are doing
what Marxists are we fighting like
please find me an actual Marxist with
any power whatsoever that Donald Trump
is fighting against I tweeted yesterday
preparing for this segment can someone
send me the name of a specific powerful
Marxist that Trump is fighting against
and someone sent me an article about
some black lives matter a person is a
quote trained Marxist I had never heard
of her and with all due respect it's not
someone who is in any way wielding any
amount of power that would be comparable
to what Donald Trump has with the bully
pulpit like if that's the woman that
Trump is fighting when he says we are
fighting Marxists then it's a really
weird fight for Trump to actually have
to wage now there were also no shortages
of glitches here's Donald Trump
struggling to say sweeping says Swift's
whiffing sift Swift completely
incoherent again this was tweeted widely
with people saying wait
people are saying Biden has dementia how
do you explain this
take a look they delivered a swift and
swooped in you know that sweeping it was
Swift and it was sweeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happened just barely
able to get the words out white
knuckling the lectern engaged in a
battle to the death with his own tongue
all really really wacky now eventually
he got to the point in his force of a
fourth of July speech where he just
lists historical figures he did this
July 3rd and Mount Rushmore already
played that for you here is Donald Trump
his list listing historical figures on
his July 4th speech and the crowd sort
of actually does start clapping I guess
it was the the most exciting thing that
Trump said George Washington
Thomas Jefferson Betsy Ross Alexander
Hamilton Benjamin Franklin John Adams
James Madison Dolly Madison the great
Frederick Douglas how weak are these
applause lines right just listing people
for the crowd to clap and it went on
like that for a while I don't want to
subject you to the entire thing
another really strange applause line was
when Trump mentioned that the virus came
from China people just starting to clap
at the mention of that fact take a look
but there and then we got hit by the
virus that came from China and we've
made a lot of progress our strategy is
moving along well now I don't at this
point want to spend a ton of time on the
China stuff the real message here is
what a deranged fourth of July speech
but it is interesting how in these China
discussions it's never mentioned that
China was the source of the virus for
every country like if if the virus
originated in China Spain was dealing
with a virus that came from China Italy
dealt with a virus that came from China
New Zealand dealt with a virus that came
from China so the fact that it came from
China doesn't change that just about
every other country dealt with the virus
better than the United States
okay Brazil is a disaster India and
Russia are not doing well I've heard of
some small countries that are not doing
well but the fact that it came from
China how does that even bear applause
and of course it has no bearing on the
fact that Trump completely failed in
terms of his dealing with the virus but
I don't want to focus too much under the
virus today but again Donald Trump
during his fourth of July speech goes
into the only reason we have so many
cases is because we have so much testing
likewise testing
there were no tests for a new virus but
now we have tested almost 40 million
people by so doing we show cases 99
percent of which are totally harmless
results that no other country can show
because no other country is testing that
we have not in terms of the numbers or
in terms of the quality remember we've
got a fact check it Trump says 99% of
cases aren't harmful that's not true
seems that the death rate is about 1%
but that doesn't mean 99% are harmful
many more people are ending up in the
hospital we still have questions about
the long-term health effect even in
people who do recover so that's wrong
our testing per capita is still just
26th in the world our deaths per capita
are the ninth highest in the world out
of more than 200 countries and
territories that have cases so the
narrative continues to be completely
untrue but his followers love it and
they fall for it and then sort of to
wrap up the 4th of July speech just one
more clip here's Trump saying that the
media slanders him when they accurately
report that something he said was either
racist or xenophobic
these are great heroes let me also say a
word to those in the media who falsely
and consistently label their opponents
as racists who condemn patriotic
citizens who offer a clear and truthful
defense of American unity that's what
our people are doing we want a clear and
faithful defense of American history and
we want unity when you level these false
charges you not only slander me
you not only slander the American people
but you slander generations of heroes
who gave their lives for America this is
just hilariously and laughably
nonsensical when you call Trump out for
doing something racist you are
slandering the troops that served in the
military in all of American history is
what Trump is saying when you point out
Trump did something racist you are
disrespecting people who served in World
War two and Vietnam like how does that
even compute and that's what Trump is
trying to convince people of and sadly
it works I tweeted yesterday that this
will work on some of his followers a
bunch of people responded saying David
you're wrong this will work on most of
his followers from the rally at least it
seemed that that did resonate with
people when the media calls Trump racist
they are disrespecting the troops if you
convince people of that in Orwellian
fashion it's almost more reminiscent of
the Testaments and oh my god what is
Margaret Atwood's first book before the
Testament that the hand mates Dale it's
more reminiscent of the type of
propaganda you see depicted by Margaret
Atwood in a Handmaid's Tale and the
Testaments and it's working on his
followers which is why even though the
polls look good for Joe Biden
I know it's gonna be an uphill battle
going into November we'll have continued
coverage of this on the David Pakman
show Instagram page at David Pakman show
for pictures of me
at the beach which are triggering men
and women alike for very different
reasons follow me on instagram at David
Mack I'm half kidding but I'm not
kidding that will be right back in two
minutes
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him welcome back to the
David Pakman show so I want to spend
just a few minutes talking about the
November 20 2011 but the context is
really going to be coronavirus because
there's a very interesting new study
which found that if you break down
Donald Trump's approval rating in
counties where coronavirus is raging
versus in counties where it is not this
is a county level analysis counties that
are seeing the highest rates of
coronavirus explosion have seen a
dramatic drop in donald trump's approval
rating and the reason this is important
is that last week i did a segment
pointing out that you know when we think
about the biden versus trump debates
assuming that they happen biden pointing
out that trump is crass and makes fun of
people and is a bully and grab them by
the you-know-what and the racism and the
xenophobia and all that stuff it hasn't
worked so far and i can't imagine that
it's going to all of a sudden start
working for joe biden if that's the
approach he decides to take my instinct
was we've seen trump's approval come
down because of three major issues over
the last four months number one the
handling of coronavirus number two the
handling of the economy in the context
of the failed handling of coronavirus
and number three the insane reaction to
protests against police brutality which
included authoritarian anti speech
tendencies and threats to send in troops
with even more force to protests that
are against police brutality to begin
with that's where the focus should be
and particularly the failure of
leadership language aside if Trump uses
coarse language but he crushes the virus
and does the right thing when it comes
to protests in the economy okay who's
gonna care about the course language and
that's basically my idea and indeed
Donald Trump has seen the fast
declines in his approval rating in the
500 counties where there have been more
than 28 coronavirus deaths per hundred
thousand residents that's sort of like
the dividing line Pew Research polling
shows that 17% of the country which
approved of Trump in March
now disapproved so it's starting with
just the slice that approved in March
17% of that now disapproves and this is
a in those counties and this is a
massive drop and we're not even near the
end of the pandemic and it's always
tragic when it takes friends or family
members getting sick or dying to wake up
and have a realization it's like the
anti-gay Republican politician who
changes their tune typically his tune
but their tune when someone they know
comes out as gay great they came to the
right conclusion but why did it take
that you couldn't empathize well it
seems like that's at least part of
what's going on here and there's a very
reasonable debate over how much is
Trump's fault in terms of the cases and
deaths obviously people were going to
die you can't say of the hundred and
thirty two thousand deaths a hundred and
thirty two thousand are Trump's fault
but you can put numbers on what was the
cost of not developing a testing program
starting January 20th the way South
Korea did when we both got our first
cases on the same day you can make
estimates about what would a mask
recommendation have done early on what
would stay at home have done early on
hospitals could have maybe not been
underwhelm like you overwhelmed you can
put numbers to this and so you know
people who want to argue Trump doesn't
have a hundred and thirty two thousand
deaths on his hands of course he doesn't
I don't know anyone who's actually
making that case what we know is that
there are specific policies and specific
actions including the rollout of the
testing program and many other things
that could have been done differently
which would have saved lives and it's
not could have been done differently but
nobody did that many countries did South
Korea is an example there are many
others
remember that on February 26 Donald
Trump said we have 15 cases and 15 is
soon going to zero that was February
26th we now have almost three million
cases and a hundred and thirty two
thousand deaths and cases are exploding
in a huge swath of this country so
that's the context and it is again
evidence that the pandemic and Trump's
reaction are dramatically hurting his
polling now to zoom out a little bit
bigger picture we continue to get
national polling where Trump is down by
double digits we also are seeing
RealClearPolitics polling averages in
Wisconsin Michigan Pennsylvania and
Florida where Biden is ahead by five or
more points that's insane Arizona which
has been a Republican stronghold for a
long time Biden ahead by an average of
three and a half and a half the really
crazy thing to think about is that if
Donald Trump had just taken medical
advice and gone the route of other
countries that chose chose science over
ignorance and action over politics if he
had controlled coronavirus and supported
a shutdown supported an actual real
testing program starting in January
tracing initiatives etc etc he would
have an all but guaranteed reelection in
November I am increasingly confident
that that is that that that is how
important this is ultimately going to be
and it's also crazy to think that if
Trump and pence had just caught the flu
or a bad intestinal bug on January 20th
and been m.i.a for a month and just let
medical doctors make decisions we would
also be far better off in other words
their presence was not only not positive
it was acutely negative in dealing with
coronavirus the data is in the polls and
so what do we all have to do now exactly
we don't believe any one of the polls we
imagine that our individual votes could
be the difference makers in our states
and every single one of us gets an
absentee ballot or goes and votes or
does whatever it is that we can do to
ensure that Donald Trump is removed in
November the polling looks good
ignore it pretend the polling looks
terrible pretend every
50/50 and that you could be the
difference-maker the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
so one of the things I looked at in
detail over the weekend is the latest
perform or version of Joe Biden's tax
plan and I want to dig into it with you
because you know we've talked about
taxation in the United States many many
times and I've talked about what I think
would be the right path forward for the
changes we need to make to how people
are taxed and there's this assumption
that Joe Biden would be extremely
centrist
in terms of his policy and in some cases
that's true and certainly on many issues
Joe Biden is is well to Bernie Sanders
right but I have to tell you that Joe
Biden's tax plan if made law and again
with any candidate we would we would
always say if made law everything is
negotiated no president gets exactly
what they want Joe Biden's tax plan
maybe one of the most progressive from
the standpoint of taxing millionaires
and in particular non-working
millionaires then any tax plan that we
have seen in the modern political era
even including Dwight D Eisenhower when
we had that top marginal tax rate of 91%
and I'm gonna explain this and and I'm
not what I'm looking here is not just
soda vision but rather to point out that
Joe Biden's tax plan is really quite
solid and and would do a lot to tax the
people that most should be taxed from
the progressive perspective a lot of
times the debate over taxes over the
last 20 years has been should the
richest pay 39 or 36 percent 39.6 or 37
percent like that's the debate that is
80 percent of the debate when we talk
about rolling back the Bush tax cuts or
rolling back the Trump what we're mostly
talking about for a lot of people right
I think it's about 500,000 and up in
income is should the richest pay 36 or
39 percent this ignores capital gains
this ignores that we need higher and
higher and bigger tax brackets etc etc
etc let's look now at some of the things
that Joe Biden has in his tax plan now I
want to remind you Dwight D Eisenhower
had these high top marginal tax rates of
like 90 percent but he had them at a
time
where
there were a ton of mechanisms to avoid
actually paying a high effective tax
rate if you were very wealthy so when
you look back at the what matters is the
effective tax rate if you look back at
the Eisenhower era even though you had
those high marginal tax rates the top 1%
of taxpayers in the 50s we're only
paying about 42 percent total of their
income in taxes so as a result the tax
burden on high-income households today
is only slightly lower than what those
same top 1% paid in the 1950s and what
Joe Biden is proposing to do could raise
taxes on the rich well beyond what they
were under the Eisenhower 91% top
marginal tax rate days because as you
can see since the early 90s the
effective tax rate on the top 1% has
bounced between 35 and 40 percent okay
so what will Joe Biden's tax plan do
number one yes it will undo those Trump
brackets that are similar to the george
w bush brackets the top tax rate will go
from 37 percent to 39.6 percent it's the
right move it's not that big of a thing
for a large swath of Americans the very
important change that Biden would make
is that earnings above 400,000 would be
subject to the social security tax of
12.1 percent
this is monstrous in terms of the total
amount of money right now you stop
paying Social Security tax at about a
hundred and thirty seven thousand
dollars in income you pay it on your
first hundred and thirty seven K then it
goes to zero what Biden proposes is
there's a doughnut hole there between a
hundred and thirty seven and four
hundred thousand where you don't pay
that twelve percent tax but then when
you get to four hundred thousand dollars
in income and going all the way up you
pay twelve point one percent that is
absolutely massive in terms of the
amount of money that would collect and
that money would be used to increase the
social security benefits for the poor so
that would actually remove hundreds of
thousands of seniors from poverty it
costs the middle
class zero and it comes from people
earning over 400,000 now you might
correctly say but but David hold on a
second sir as Donald Trump says David a
lot of the rich are the non-working rich
they're not earning wages so they
wouldn't be affected by that and you're
completely correct the other thing that
Joe Biden's tax plan would do is remove
the lower capital gains rate on
dividends and the long-term capital
gains rate if you make over 1 million
dollars per year so the non-working
millionaires would be paying in
dramatically more money because they
would have to pay their income tax rate
rather than the capital gains rate on a
whole bunch of dividends and capital
gains this could double the tax rate for
non-working millionaires who get most of
their income from investments also very
importantly Biden is calling for a full
repeal of stepped-up basis now what did
this requires a little bit of
explanation but what this means is if
someone donates imagine that someone
buys a thousand dollars worth of stock
in the 1970s they die and they give you
a million dollars worth of stock that's
a huge gain right it went from a
thousand to a million dollars there's a
cartoonish example what the stepped-up
basis allows is that if you is the heir
with that stock decide to sell it at a
time when it's worth 1 point 1 million
dollars stepped-up basis allows you to
only pay gains on the gain from the time
you inherited the stock to the time that
you sell it so even though the person
who gave you the stock the stock went
from a thousand dollars to a million
dollars in value when you got it it was
worth a million and it went up to 1.1
you only pay capital gains on that
hundred thousand dollars from a million
to one point one that is a massive
massive handout on which taxes could be
levied and it is not and it is estimated
to be if a Joe Biden were to eliminate
the the stepped-up basis
provision that would be more than four
trillion dollars of a tax increase on
the rich so joe biden's tax plan
actually does a lot of good now let's be
thorough it doesn't do a lot of things
that we should be looking at that other
candidates have proposed joe biden has
not proposed a financial transaction tax
a little slice which could be used to
fund all sorts of important programs joe
biden doesn't do that joe biden has
found or joe biden's plan does not
include higher tax brackets with higher
interest rates so right now if you you
would cap out around six hundred
thousand dollars with a thirty with
Biden's tax funded be thirty nine point
six percent you pay beyond six hundred
thousand dollars in earnings we probably
should have a tax bracket at forty
percent between six hundred thousand and
a million in earnings we should have a
forty five percent tax bracket between
one and three million
etc Joe Biden doesn't do that I think
that we need that and then number three
to the dismay of some people Joe Biden's
plan doesn't include a wealth tax
now I actually don't think a wealth tax
would ever pass so so while it's an
interesting idea I'm not going crazy
because Joe Biden doesn't include it but
if we look at the reality if we look at
the analysis that the Tax Policy Center
has done of this plan three quarters of
the increases fall on the richest 1% and
a whole bunch of that other twenty five
percent is on the top five percent this
is a very progressive tax plan compared
to what we've seen certainly for the
last 50 even a hundred years in the
United States
I'm not saying Joe Biden is the greatest
period but let's be honest and look at
the tax plan for what it is speaking by
the way of understanding math I
predicted this would happen and it's
happening we did a video a couple months
ago six weeks ago called you're about to
get slammed with the garbage math and in
that video I made the case that after
these massive declines in the stock
market in employment job loss
sumer spending all of the stuff because
of coronavirus at some point from this
insane bottom you would start to see a
recovery and percentage-wise the
recovery might look good so you would
start to see headlines like and we have
air travel up 120 % oh my god
120 % will hold on it was down 96% to
only 4% of what it was when it goes up
120 % it's up to 9 percent of what it
was let's not go crazy but this is the
type of math that they are going to use
to trick you and I said it's going to
happen with stocks it's going to happen
with jobs and we are seeing it last week
headlines four point eight million jobs
created remember we lost 46 million jobs
4.8 million came back Donald Trump went
on a national bragging tour about this
is the fastest and best job creation in
the history of the United States well
hold on a second
first of all we got four million jobs
back after losing 46 million number two
what did Trump do to actually get those
jobs back we would have way more jobs
back had we had a competent federal
response to coronavirus rather than what
we experienced again bragging
unemployment rate down to 11% this is
the biggest one-month drop in
unemployment in history hold on a second
we had unemployment of 16 17 % real
unemployment arguably 20% you're
bragging now that we still have
historically high unemployment and they
are doing the full garbage math
treatment here's Donald Trump himself
just a few days ago the United States
economy added almost 5 million jobs in
the month of June shattering all
expectations I was watching this morning
and the expectations were much lower
than that the stock market is doing
extremely well which means to me jobs
what it means jobs does the largest
monthly jobs gain in the history of our
country the unemployment rate fell by
more than two percentage points
down to just about 11% we're down to the
11% number we started at a number very
much higher than that as you know we
broke the record last month and we broke
it again this month in an even bigger
way this news comes on top of May's
extraordinary jobs report the largest
job gain in history why well it sounds
like things are going pretty well right
oh wait a second
we lost 46 million jobs before gaining
4.8 million jobs now I think this is a
good time to remind you I want a good
economy I don't want any jobs lost in
order to hurt Donald Trump politically I
don't want any coronavirus cases or
deaths to hurt Donald Trump politically
the reality is of course employment is
still well below the pre-pandemic level
we are obviously still in a huge huge
hole 15 million fewer jobs in June than
in February the unemployment rate is
down most recently from fourteen point
seven to eleven point one at eleven
point one it is still higher than at any
time since World War two and again
there's a reporting error that continues
to plague these numbers the real number
is twelve point one the data from before
this data is from before the spikes that
we've seen in Arizona and Texas and
others Texas is sort of softening their
opening telling a lot of people that
they should stay home so let's see where
things look in another month or two if
the pandemic continues to explode and
you know the realistic expectation is we
would see slow improvement to the
numbers as we get closer to the end of
2020 and we are in all likelihood going
to start 2021 in a significantly worse
position than we started 2020 that's the
reality so do not fall for the garbage
math the you what I think is missing
from a lot of these analyses is the
economy can't fully recover
mathematically until the pandemic is
under control what I mean by that is
until people get all their earnings back
they don't have the money to buy stuff
at the rate at which they were
previously that's just math it's simple
math if you don't have as much money as
you did before you can't spend as much
money as you were spending before until
hospitals can do non-emergency
procedures
full the medical healthcare industry is
not going to recover now I think our
industry is a complete immoral joke the
reality is that it's a huge industry
that makes a lot of money until people
are going back to the doctor the way
they were before for elective and
non-emergency procedures the industry
mathematically cannot recover until dine
in and dine out restaurants are fully
open and safe restaurants can't recover
it's just math if people aren't going
back and the capacity is diminished the
industry cannot recover
it's just simple arithmetic and we've
not even started to see the fall
semester at colleges and universities
depending on how that goes you could see
massive economic fallout in the 2021
academic year there so do not be tricked
I want things to recover as quickly as
possible but until we actually have the
pandemic under control from a
straight-up math perspective it cannot
happen it simply cannot happen we have a
voicemail number that number is two one
nine two david p this may be one of the
craziest calls that we've ever received
buckle up folks hey prick 'less why
don't you grow up here if you had a pair
why don't you go back to Venezuela right
away get here go back here and my 14
year old daughter coming kick your bony
ass right right I guess that's it well
listen I don't it's possible that your
14 year old daughter is very very strong
and could kick my ass I don't know that
I just haven't met her I'm not sure
about that now I've never been to
Venezuela and I've completely condemned
the Chavez's Maduro regime we just have
a new report out about the number of
deaths at the hands of the Venezuelan
military Venezuela is not a place I've
ever been to it is certainly not a place
I'm going to anytime soon so go back to
Venezuela seems like a real question
mark we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about no protest
zones we will talk about the real dog
human age multiplier and we're also
going to talk about Michael Cohen
spotted at a Manhattan restaurant
allegations swirling about whether he
needs to be sent back to prison because
of that
all of those stories and more on the
bonus show remember that next Tuesday is
the third David Pakman show chess
tournament and our big July one day
membership special get on the newsletter
at david pakman.com to get notified
about both of those exciting events